brighter Civil War soldier trapper
Buffalo hunter actor conservationist
entrepreneur and Congressional Medal of
Honor winner he's the subject of Lewis
Warren's new book Buffalo Bills America
this talk from the center of the
American West is an hour our speaker
tonight is remarkable himself on many
counts
I first met Louise Warren when he was a
graduate student at Yale and I was back
in New Haven having a quiet case of
post-traumatic stress syndrome and
countering ghosts from my own days in
graduate school when I met Lois I
emerged at least briefly from that fog
of ancient memory and I thought to
myself this is a talented young man and
a Western Australian to keep an eye on
at about the same time I went to work
according another round of post
traumatic stress syndrome by talking
about the changing field of Western
American history to lots of reporters
and getting involved in some rather
heated and polemical exchanges about the
racial exclusiveness of the conventional
views of the Western past but where I
really courted risk wasn't in the fact
that I asserted repeatedly and very
audibly that the field of Western
history was on the edge of a renaissance
after dwindling dramatically in numbers
of scholars working in this field I kept
asserting we were about to reverse this
trend and we would have a whole new
level of pepper and perkiness and
vitality and productivity and fresh
perspectives the anxiety in this phase
of life came from the fact that I did
not know if what I was saying was true I
went ahead and I kept saying it anyway
but my fingers were crossed and I was
hoping hard that my declarations were
going to prove prophetic since they did
not at all describe the world I actually
lived in and then thank heavens it
turned out that my declarations of a
renaissance were prophetic one occasion
for learning that I had gotten this
right and I was not going to be
humiliated by having proclaimed a
renaissance that never happened one
occasion came with the publication of
Louie Warren's first book the hunters
game a most original and insightful
study of early conservation and
on-the-ground politics of early nature
preserves this is a fine book for all
sorts of reasons and one big reason is
that it gave us a far clearer view of
what the designation of areas as nature
preserves meant to the local people
living in the vicinity of those
preserves it showed us that these early
acts of conservation were a lot more
complicated and their power politics
than they were in their abstraction and
that is a lesson that is one that we
could profitably
play everyday in the West and yet it
must be said that my personal reason for
celebrating Louis Warren's first book is
that it sure do mr. E's well-being we're
going to get verified and thus in other
words the publication of the hunter's
game redeemed my honor and that is a
very good reason to like a book I do not
believe that the redeeming of my honor
played any part in the decision of the
National cowboy Hall of Fame and giving
this book the Western Heritage Award for
outstanding nonfiction book but maybe
I'm wrong about that since the redeeming
of woman's honor was a big part of the
traditional cowboy role speaking of the
way that we think of mounted men in the
Western past William F Cody is by many
measures the most influential figure of
all when it comes to shaping popular
images of this region I spent a number
of years in my own career fruitlessly
and futile II challenging Cody's legacy
a legacy extremely well installed in
many many minds both in the United
States and internationally and what you
might if you like consider it if you if
you can't beat them join them strategy I
have tried to dress in Cody's honor
tonight and I am admitting publicly
tonight that I have been over the years
the recipient of two not one to any
oakley pocket knives which I have one of
which I have brought with me and I will
begin I think a tradition of carrying
them with me to Senate American West
events for those rare occasions when we
need to be reminded of the Senators firm
commitment to civil and open exchange
for heaven's sake what could I admit by
that terrible remark lui Boren taught at
the University Louie Warren taught at
the University of San Diego and then
moved to the University of California at
Davis where he's a professor he has been
working for a number of years on this
important study of William F Cody and we
are fortunate to have him here tonight
to invite us into the world of his
important new book Buffalo Bills America
thank you all for turning out tonight
it's it's great to have such a terrific
crowd book TV is here from c-span
so yeah it's here for book TV yeah we
don't have an applause light up there or
up there that you can see so Patty's
going to wave her hat at intervals
during the lecture where ponder to burst
into applause and you guys in the front
row of the balcony are going to get
confetti in just a minute you can throw
that out at odd intervals just to convey
the whole spirit of this event and and
to let people at home watching this on
book TV know how really wonderful this
lecture is that's that would be
excellent
as usual with William Cody the best way
to start is with this story in the
spring of 1883
William F Buffalo Bill Cody a one-time
Buffalo hunter an army scout who was
already a well-known theatrical
performer held the first dress rehearsal
for what would become Buffalo Bill's
Wild West Show in Colville Nebraska
according to an eyewitness when the
deadwood stagecoach trundled into the
arena Buffalo Bill invited the Town
Council including the mayor a beloved
but notorious blusterer named PAP
clothier to ride in the coach and for
the first two passes around the show
grounds the coach rolled merrily along
and its occupants waved to the crowd on
the third pass the Pawnee Indian
performers swept into the arena on
horseback the coach passengers were
expecting it but the Mules had not been
advised of this part of the program
according to the eyewitness the animals
surged forward the Indians in hot
pursuit the driver barely able to keep
the coach's wheels on the ground as it
rounded the turn when Buffalo Bill and
his Cowboys suddenly went into action as
the rescue party nobody had told the
pawnees to break off the attack
terrified by several dozen howling men
on horseback and the thunder of guns
firing blanks
the Mules stepped up the pace as the
coach Indians Scouts and Cody swept past
the crowd again the mayor stuck his head
out the window waved his hands
frantically and shouted stop pal stop
let us out but the driver had all he
could do to keep the stage on its
circular course without rolling it over
the Mules didn't hold until they were
thoroughly winded at that point the
enraged mayor lept out of the excuse me
we're not going to restart now we're
going to restart later yeah the enraged
mayor left out of the coach and made for
Buffalo Bill ready for a fight
fortunately before PAP clothier could
reach Cody a local lawyer and wit named
Frank Evers climbed to the top of the
coach look at them gentlemen he
announced pointing to the day's town
council and the infuriated Mayor Evers
declaimed his pride in these
and who risked their lives for your
entertainment clothier now turned back
to the coach and went after Evers who
escaped it was an uncertain beginning
for an entertainment with which the
already famed Buffalo Bill hoped to
catch what he called the better class of
customers the first year on the road
unfortunately wasn't much better despite
the fact that the show already included
many of the action tableaus that made it
famous horse races between different
races sharpshooting displays a buffalo
hunt and of course the attack on the
deadwood stage that year when the show
season ended in Chicago audiences were
sparse one reviewer marveled at the
audacity of William Cody and his
partners who seemed to have assembled a
show of ferocious looking prairie
terrors for the entertainment of street
urchins not for the first time nor for
the last Cody was nearly broke and yet
as we know Buffalo Bill's Wild West went
on to fabulous success becoming the best
known representation of the American
West and more than that the best-known
representation of the United States in
most of the world in subsequent years
this traveling community of Indians
Cowboys Mexican Vaqueros and others
numbered as many as 700 people the show
entertained North Americans and
Europeans for 33 years at various points
appearing before the Queen of England
and many other notables Cody's success
in Britain and Europe validated American
culture and American history as
respectable entertainment and as frankly
as culturally significant Cody was far
more than the nostalgic rustic figure
historians and biographers have claimed
he was a national icon and an
international celebrity back home in the
closing decade and a half of the 19th
century the popularity of Buffalo Bill's
Wild West was all the more remarkable
given popular anxieties of the time
picture a nation bitterly divided
between two political parties who were
almost
we matched from the stolen election of
1876 to the election of 1900 Artie's who
fought bitterly over elections at every
level of government the Industrial
Revolution that was turning America into
a nation of city dwellers brought on
fierce labor unrest from the great
strike of 1877 during which the
Pittsburgh railroad station was burned
to the ground that's what you see here
to the Haymarket bombing of 1886 some
people called it what it's sometimes
referred to as the first terrorist
strike in modern America as certainly
was called that at the time and the
Pullman Strike of 1893 to 94 there were
a huge number of altercations between
labor and capital
labor and capital many people felt
seemed to be at a level a stage of
low-level civil war between 1881 and
1904 there were an estimated 37,000
recorded strikes meanwhile all those
middle class men and women who are
moving to the cities faced a series of
challenges of their own people who are
leaving the farms and moving to the
cities to take up jobs in offices
middle-class white men in particular
while becoming clerks and managers and
feared becoming over civilized in the
parlance of the time feared that while
their father's new nature and their
fathers knew the farm they shuffled
paper and they weren't really men amidst
these political and social upheavals
Cody's show was popular on the political
right Frederick Remington who had very
conservative political views and that
might be putting it mildly
adored the Wild West Show and many of
his most famous paintings of the West
are actually based on scenes in the show
he would visit the show especially in
New York and borrow cowboys and Indians
for poses in his studio but it was also
popular on the left among the Wild West
shows fans was Edward Aveling
the son-in-law of Karl Marx and an
eminent socialist in his own right
Edward Aveling was the first Thea
to come up with a with a diagnosis of
the cowboy condition in which he said
the cowboy is as much a slave to the
capitalist as the Massachusetts mill
hand as a sort of cowboy as proletarian
but Edward Aveling loved the Wild West
Show he first saw it in New York
he wrote rave reviews of it and he said
he then went on and spent time with the
show when it visited London he would say
have I not spent days and nights and
camp with them been present at saddle up
time and been behind the scenes of the
performances ridden outside the deadwood
coach slept in Buffalo Bills tent
without question Buffalo Bill's Wild
West was the greatest generator of
Western myth prior to the invention of
the movies it not only made Cody wealthy
it made him the most famous American in
the world by 1900 it didn't end until
1913 when he lost the show in bankruptcy
court but even then Cody rode his fame
to other shows until 1917 on news of his
death that year poet EE Cummings called
to mind his vision of Cody from the show
Cody's signature act in the Wild West
Show was to ride fast around the arena
top speed while an assistant also on
horseback through balls made of amber
into the air and Cody would blast those
balls from the air using his rifle EE
Cummings recalled Buffalo Bills defunct
who used to ride a water smooth silver
stallion and break one two three four
five pigeons just like that Jesus he was
a handsome man so what went wrong that
first year and what did Cody do to make
the show successful most of all what
does all that success
tell us about America in William Cody's
time to answer all these questions which
are many of the questions that energized
me when I began this book the whole
problem of explaining how a man goes
from frontier Kansas to becoming the
most famous showman in the world
is such a strange story I grew up in
Nevada and as a child I liked two kinds
of stories most of all one stories about
the Wild West I would read
books about about about the the
nineteenth-century West and the Wild
West Show and what attracted me to the
Wild West Show was the other kind of
story of life which is the strange but
true story you know get collections of
strange Midori's and it usually usually
feature tales about Bigfoot and all
kinds of other things but this story
about this guy who went from Kansas to
showmanship playing himself seemed the
weirdest story of all in some ways who
was he born William Frederick Cody near
LeClair Iowa in 1846 he moved to Kansas
when he was still a young child after
the death of his father
young will Cody became a boyhood
teamster he was an anti-slavery
Jayhawker in the Bleeding Kansas trouble
troubles and in 1864 he joined the Union
Army and fought briefly in the south
after the war he became a Buffalo hunter
for the Kansas Pacific Railroad and
distinguished himself as a scout for the
army in the plains Indian Wars in 1869
he was discovered by the dime novelist
Ned Buntline which was the pen name of a
very well known writer named ezc Judson
and Judson or Buntline was renowned as
the most well paid writer in America it
was rumored he was making $20,000 a year
at the time he went west
partly to find somebody to write about
he was probably looking for someone else
probably Wild Bill Hickok possibly the
Scout Frank north and he found William
Cody instead he published a story called
Buffalo Bill the king of the border men
which was serialized in the story paper
the New York weekly by this time Cody
was all it was also a hunting guide to
army officers and wealthy tourists many
of whom arrived in Kansas wanting to
hunt Buffalo in 1872 general Phil
Sheridan invited him to guide the
glamorous Plains hunt of the Grand Duke
calexis of Russia who was also
accompanied by George a Custer
that's Custer on your left and the Grand
Duke Alexis in the middle the man on the
right is William Cody who wasn't
actually in the studio that day he grew
kind of jealous about this picture later
on and in his publicity he
took the photo of Custer and the Grand
Duke and had himself spliced in just to
make that heroic triumvirate work after
the hunt with the Grand Duke Alexis Cody
accepted an invitation from some of his
hunting clients including the publisher
James Gordon Bennett jr. who was the
publisher of the of the very influential
newspaper the New York Herald to visit
New York society while in New York
he saw a play in a theater not unlike
the one we're in where an actor named JB
studly was playing Buffalo Bill in a
play alleged to be about Buffalo Bills
life and according to Cody he was
sitting in the balcony in a box and then
the the actor JB Studley announced in
the middle of the play said ladies and
gentlemen are actually gentlemen because
it pretty much an all-male all-male
audience at the time he said with us
tonight is the real Buffalo Bill and the
crowd brought the house down all right
did they move brought the house down a
Cody professed great embarrassment but
was ultimately persuaded later that year
that he should return to New York and
play himself on the stage first though
he went west again scouted for the army
again and was awarded the Congressional
Medal of Honor for fighting the Lakota
Sioux and it was that fall of 1872 that
he returned to the east and began his
stage career in what we would call
frontier melodramas plays about the
redemption of the good woman from the
clutches of evil in which Buffalo Bill
alleged the story was actually true and
would say these stories are actually
about my life and in fact they were
highly fictionalized and he would always
play himself Buffalo Bills this the
Buffalo Bill combination was the name of
his theater company and for the duration
of the 1870s then he toured with this
Theatre Company throughout the United
States
returning to the plains in the summer to
scout for the army or to guide wealthy
tourists on Buffalo hunting expeditions
that's Buffalo Bill Cody in the middle
and the man on the right on the left is
Ned Buntline and the man on the far
right is Texas Jack Omohundro who was
another frontier army scout who had
turned his life into
it turned into this same career of
acting at playing himself in these Wild
West before in the frontier melodramas
what inspired cody to mix historical
action and reenactment in this way
without spending too much time on that
question I do think it's important to
understand exactly
Cody's sense of his preternatural sense
of cultural longings and its intuitive
grasp of a few particulars about
American culture
the first thing he understood that gave
him an advantage over so many other
would-be performers was the importance
of a story and it was a very particular
story
most Americans knew the West as a
setting for that story which was the
story of the progress of civilization
which was usually told in classrooms
elementary school classrooms in public
lectures in popular articles in
newspapers that from the beginning from
near the beginning of the nineteenth
century onward that story was usually
told in four parts that is that all
civilizations it was thought advanced
through stages of development beginning
with hunting and progressing to herding
and then going on to farming and finally
Commerce which would bring urbanism and
trade this is a very famous painting
from 1872 John gasps American Progress
in which you can see the story mapped
out for us here that the hunters on the
far left are Indians and they're being
pushed off the screen by the forces of
progress who are arriving miners here
but most importantly down here I love
this part farmers who are plowing their
way west I mean look at the facts you
got the plow in the road and there's a
plow II take a little while to get out
there but they're not gonna quit there
they're the ones who bring in their
train all of this development we have
the goddess of Liberty who's stringing
the telegraph wire and behind her along
with her is becoming the railroad and in
the far distance advancing West is the
city and the Commerce another way to
think about this
story was that the wilderness was being
domesticated and being turned into a
garden and that somehow this the the
savage dark wilderness would be turned
into productive farm fields and all of
this technology would also somehow
combine to create a grand and glorious
and hopefully eternal Yeomans Republic
but just as important as the store
that's that was the story of the nation
but just as important to Cody's success
here is he took that story as his own
story the nation develops and stages and
so do I I was a hunter he would say I
became a rancher and then I got
domesticated he would say and he would
talk about the house he had I'll talk
about that in just a few moments and and
his family and so forth so that the
story of the nation's progress becomes
internalized to himself but it just as
important as all of that was Cody's
intuition of public doubts about this
story how could you know what was
actually happening out west
after all unless you went there yourself
you relied on newspapers on dime novels
on theater productions on paintings
that's how you knew what was going on
out west and how did you know that stuff
was true because there was an explosion
of printed material in the 19th century
the steam-powered printing press makes
its debut and it really expands after
the middle of the 19th century and
millions of pages of newspaper print
real estate ads autobiographies which
are often fictionalized right all of
these things pour off the presses and
the great challenge becomes how do we
know it's true what we're reading in the
newspapers this development of what we
call print culture it was one of the
things that encouraged the development
also of a lot of fraud in particular in
the West there was no place like the
West for finding advertisements for you
know great land deals the railroads
sent out advertisements saying you can
come here and settle on this beautiful
green verdant land and have a great farm
and you all know how the story often
went you ended up on land that well
a little bit less than ideal for farming
shall we say Cody understood though
something else about the problem of
fraud and print and representation from
being in the West he came to understand
that artful deception if it was staged
as entertainment could draw a public
crowd that wanted to be amused and he
learned this in part his experiences in
the West and in part from his travels in
the east where the most popular
entertainer of the day was probably PT
Barnum PT Barnum who developed a form of
entertainment in which the hoax was
elevated to kind of an art form
what PT Barnum would do was to create
some attraction in this case the Fiji
mermaid which was a dot the head of a
veil or the tort or so rather of a of a
monkey sewn to the tail of a fish and it
was a hideous thing actually but it was
so carefully sewn together you couldn't
tell where the stitches were and Barnum
swore that he bought the thing from a
sailor who came from the South Seas and
he would say I don't know if it's true I
don't know if it's legitimate I have no
idea but take a look it's 25 cents take
a look just for 25 cents right here you
go on in and the crowd loved it because
they could go in and investigate the
thing and make up their own minds even
when they thought he was not presenting
them with a legitimate attraction they
enjoyed the spectacle of a carefully
wrought hoax and they appreciated his
willingness to let them make up their
own minds about it as long as you
weren't claiming to sell the unvarnished
truth and as long as your attraction was
well presented enough to inspire
uncertainty and fairly priced the
audience would not desert you Barnum
would say for example the public is
inclined to be amused even when they are
aware of being deceived and it was a
kind of a great spirit of mid 19th
century democratic spectatorship
that the audience member had the power
to discern reality beneath all those
layers of fakery in the culture around
them and if you could make a spectacle
out of that you had a really live
attraction for most Americans to go west
was to explore the degree to which those
popular representations of the West
captured Western reality those who
recorded their journeys in the West
often explained to their readers what
they should believe about other places
other things they had read right and
what they should not if you read
accounts of immigrants on the Overland
Trail during the gold rush they're full
of advice about which guidebooks you can
believe and which ones are fraudulent
there's lots of this kind of experience
of the West meanwhile various
individuals in the West began to make
popular attractions by staging their
lives as ongoing shows of Western
progress dime novel plots brought to
life and inviting tourists and other
spectators to decide for themselves
whether the act was true or not a past
master of this form of entertainment was
a friend of Cody's and sort of his
mentor in 1867 68 in Hays Kansas James
Butler Hickok known to his friends and
to his enemies as Wild Bill who would
often dress instead of dressing like
this which is the way that many
nineteenth-century men in Kansas were
dressing you add a suit jacket on top of
that and you would have the way most men
in Kansas were dressing he would show up
at the railroad station when the
tourists came in dressed like this and
start telling stories about his
adventures and the tourists would hire
him to guide them on some kind of trip
out of town a hunting trip a trip to
look at some real estate and so forth in
going to the stage in the east
Cody frequently used Hickox Legend
Hickok was well known in the popular
press he used Hickox legend to draw
attention to himself and in fact he
invited Wild Bill Hickok to join his
stage troupe in 1873 and 74 this is Wild
Bill Hickok right here with the gun
upside down clowning
for the camera William Cody and again
Texas Jack Omohundro there were in fact
dozens of men who'd set about trying to
create themselves as to stage a sari to
mingle the stage and the real to present
themselves as an attraction not a monkey
fish or an ape-man but the ideal man the
embodiment of frontier progress and
there was a vigorous competition to
become that ideal man among these three
figures and dozens of others we forgot
the Scout Donald McKay from the Modoc
Wars dashing Charlie Emmett who was also
from out in Nebraska all of these men
were on the stage in what was called at
the time the Scout business it was in
1876 that Cody demonstrated his Matt his
mastery of though of mingling action and
reenactment when he returned to the
plains to scout for the army in the
Sioux campaign of that year while
scouting for General Eugene Carr he
learned that Custer had been killed at
the Little Bighorn dressing in a stage
costume of black velvet with scarlet
slashing and silver buttons and trim
this was an outfit he'd worn on the
stage he rode into battle where he
killed and scalped a Cheyenne man named
yellow hair taking what Cody claimed was
the first scalp for Custer the name was
subsequently mistranslated his yellow
hand and Cody sent the scalp and other
belongings of the Fallen warrior to his
newly adopted hometown of Rochester New
York where they were exhibited in the
window of a shop belonging to a friend
that fall onstage he put on the same
outfit in which he had killed yellow
hair and then he had somebody dress up
his yellow hair and re-enacted a highly
theatrical version of the killing and
held up the real scalp for the audience
rear was in a sense a means of taking
the frontier show of that heroic life
had progress and moving it East to
bigger audiences who enthusiastically
debated the many questions swirling
around him was he really who the dime
novels said he was was he somebody
pretending to be a dime novel character
was there a real Buffalo Bill and if so
was this him was he a frontiersman or
was he a showman
but the theatrical Fame wore thin Cody
had trouble attracting audiences of
sufficient size and respectability
mistaking yellow hair scalp proved to be
at best at best mixed results for him he
was widely condemned in the middle-class
press they even the New York Herald
which have been his biggest backers
denounced it as an affront to our
civilization a stooping to savagery at
the time the theatrical world of the
time wasn't really a great place for
making yourself into a national
phenomenon in this kind of stage play
theaters were frequented by two groups
of people broadly speaking in at this
point in the 19th century the
upper-class who went to plays about
Shakespeare plays in French right and
the working class who went to raucous
theatres where all kinds of things were
exhibited on stage and where men
predominated in the audience and in the
galleries up top and when the galleries
up top didn't like what they were seeing
they'd start hurling all kinds of things
that the action actors on stage
including peanuts thus the term the
peanut gallery
Cody was stuck in those theaters that's
where his fame was greatest the middle
class didn't really attend theaters and
their demographic was the one with the
most rapidly increasing disposable
income so he made the move which brought
him worldwide fame ultimately when he
organized the Wild West Show and took it
on the road beginning in 1883 even more
than the show shows shooting and writing
skills its premiere attraction was the
presence of real Indians the sitting
bolt and his family who toured with the
show in 1885 Indians came to the show
for reasons of their own it was
relatively good work
it allowed travel allowed the
continuance of ceremonies and dances
banned on the reservation to American
audiences they represented the beginning
of the story of progress the primitives
who would be overwhelmed by civilization
in the show's drama but of course
Indians had been with the show that
first year and much of Cody's success
flowed from how he wrapped that story of
advancing civilization
the presence of genuine Indians most
historians trace Cody's success to his
reenactments of the Battle of Little
Bighorn but in fact the staging of
Custer's defeat was a relative rarity
the finale of the show was almost always
almost always the same and it was the
attack on the settlers cabin which was
introduced introduced in the show's
second season in 1884 why this scene
which is a scene generally of a white
woman and children in a cabin in which
Indians attack and Buffalo Bill and the
Cowboys ride to the rescue and sometimes
there weren't any white children around
to put in so the indian children would
sometimes play the white children inside
the cabin but why do I use that scene
remember that the treasure Cody seeks is
the middle-class audience especially
middle-class women if you get
middle-class women to come to your show
they'll bring their husbands they'll
bring their children they'll bring a lot
of money and you will retire as he loved
to talk about retiring rich that was his
great dream and you would be established
as a respectable entertainer few
middle-class people actually ventured
out for entertainment in this time the
phenomenon that what we call going out
that term arrives in American English
about this time in the 1880s 90s as
people begin to find ways of drawing
middle-class audiences out for the
evening to lure these people out you had
to persuade them use their seeing
something respectable William Cody's
show career presented him as the
embodiment of frontier development and
his show as a living exhibition of his
life his show publicity said again he'd
passed through every phase of frontier
development so domestication became
central to the show's version of
frontier history and part of the climax
of Cody's own biography which was
reprinted in all every show program was
this scene for example of the frontier
in the old days and Buffalo Bill's home
in Nebraska today with this barn that
said Scouts rest ranch across the roof I
was wondering why he had it written in
letters big enough to be seen from an
air
plain this photo is from 1892 and I
think the kit it's not an airplane turns
out that you could at the time see it
from the train going past from the Union
Pacific and he wanted his audiences
audience members who rode on the train
to know when they were passing Buffalo
Bills real-life ranch you can see the
scene from savage frontier at the top to
domesticated pastoral at the bottom and
a poem at the middle talking about lines
witness inspired on witnessing the
Prairie chief caressing his baby
daughter little Emma Cody in which it
talks about how the Slayer of yellow
hand is now some has become domesticated
by the presence of a baby and of course
the presence of a wife who provided that
baby first the show for families then
culminated with a scene of white family
defense and beginning in 1885 the
presence of Gentile women in the show
added to its veneer of respectability
now there were women involved with the
show from the very beginning
particularly Indian women who
responsible in the in the show company
for taking care of those Indian children
right and who also provide a home
environment for a lot of the men who
were performing Cody encouraged whole
Indian families to come along on the
road for a whole variety of reasons but
the first women who would be who could
be identified in the action as
middle-class audience the first of these
was of course Annie Oakley Cody and his
new partner hired her in 1885 and her
shooting was central to the show's
appeal she had grown up a hard scramble
well she'd grown up in a hardscrabble
childhood in Ohio and developed
remarkable shooting skills as a market
hunter in April 1884 she shot nine
hundred and forty three out of a
thousand glass balls thrown into the air
using a 22 caliber rifle in February of
1885 she loaded her own shotguns in a
nine-hour marksmanship marathon that saw
her shatter four thousand seven hundred
and seventy two glass balls out of five
thousand thrown one of the things that
people commented on at the time was at
men who tried similar feats were often
so sore halfway through
they couldn't finish it took a
tremendous amount of actual physical
strength to accomplish that as well as
skilled with a gun she mastered the
quintessential masculine technology of
the day the gun and what's more she
raised it to Frank Butler her manager
and her husband he held the targets
cigarettes off which she shot the Ember
dimes held between his thumb and
forefinger cards he pulled out these
things that look like playing cards one
after the other and she would shoot them
in rapid succession then he would turn
around the audience and fling them into
the audience just sort of like a
somebody dealing cards right and the
audience members would grab for these
things and look at them and they would
be a something about the size of a
playing card with a 2 inch by 2 inch
heart in the middle with a bullet hole
through the center her marksmanship was
a demonstration of many things that
don't have time to go into here but
among the things that she was presenting
was that I've argued in the book the the
good woman could contain the destructive
energies of the industrial world and of
male profligacy cigarettes money cards a
true woman could help her husband direct
his energies away from those things and
she did it in the most spectacular
fashion
historians are right to emphasize the
show as a spectacle of masculine power
but we must take note of how much that
spectacle relied on professional women
performers one of the reasons why Cody
endorsed woman suffrage in 1894 was to
draw more professional middle
middle-class women who desired to be
professionals there were professional
women's associations in New York who
visited the show and he wanted to draw
more of their custom to his exhibition
most historians see the show as a
spectacle of the authentic but its
allure I think lay more in its mixture
of the real and the fake Annie Oakley
was no Westerner Cody began to layer he
layered lots of different stories on top
of his real frontier accomplishments he
said he was in the Pony Express he
wasn't he said he accomplished all kinds
of things on the battlefield which he
never had he said he was Custer
Custer's he said he was Custer's guide
he never guided for Custer and in fact
doesn't appear to have liked him very
much while the man was alive but even
with all that if you knew any of that
you had to admire the audacity of the
show the skill with which it was carried
off the verb of the pose for the rest of
the show's life
Cody worked hard to retain its relevance
for larger and increasingly diverse
audiences and the changes he brought to
it in the 1890s
extended its appeal even further in 1893
he revamped his show into Buffalo Bill's
Wild West and Congress of Rough Riders
of the world incorporating Russian
Cossacks actually Georgian trick riders
and Gauchos and Arab riders and
contingents of European cavalry there
are lots of ways of thinking about this
show and many people say well it
expresses America's longing for empire
after all America was grabbing the
Philippines right grabbed Cuba in this
period there's some truth to that but
the most striking thing about the
discussion of the show in the popular
press is how much it engaged the public
on more familiar ground on problems
around the public everyday problems of
urban living of industrialization and
immigration the best example of that is
in Brooklyn in 1894 when the Wild West
Show set up near the ferry docks right
down here you can see here where we are
and this arrow points to it and you
could follow the ferry routes to know
how to get to the show when you saw this
very large poster anywhere in New York
City the Wild West Show set up for six
months at this site this Brooklyn was at
this time a thriving City it was the
fourth largest industrial city in
America it was also an immigrant city
three hundred thousand Brooklyn Heights
had been born in Germany another ninety
thousand had been born in Ireland and
another 300,000 were the american-born
children of these German and Irish
immigrants the show helped express many
things for the audiences in Brooklyn
it's widely known among historians that
it helped Express middle-class white
fears about savage immigrants and the
dangerous City the city was a pair
journalist place full of alien peoples
and strange slums and vice and it's well
established that for example this is the
seventh cavalry charging into the Lakota
who are here that's a giant painting of
the Little Bighorn Valley this is the
Brooklyn arena in 1894 and what's
happening is that's cavalry will charge
forward and then the Lakota will mass
out of the painting and sort of swallow
them into the painting and into history
they at this time the 7th cavalry had
also been in Chicago to help put down
the Pullman Strike so it's widely
acknowledged that some people would have
seen this and thought yeah strikers
Indians they're all savages and they
need to be put down by the army
some people doubtless saw it that way
but in general immigrants loved this
show and the reasons are pretty plain to
see Jim immigrants and their
american-born children confronted
popular prejudices by seeking out
rituals of assimilation in the 1890s and
one of these was going to popular
amusements becoming part of a large and
diverse American public the names of the
cowboy and army contingents in the show
were printed in show souvenirs and
they're full of Irish and German last
names McCormick Gallagher Ryan
McPhee France Ken Stein these are the
names of net either naturalized
immigrants who became Cowboys and
soldiers or their children and the show
suggested the pot the possibilities for
naturalization immigrants and their
children were playing an increasingly
large part in American political life
but American history at this point
generally didn't include them the same
summer that Buffalo Bill was showing
this spectacle of world history as he
called it the Brooklyn Historical
Society was putting on for Father's Day
for Father's Day was where you
encouraged the public to celebrate the
history of New England this was their
idea of a grand public celebration in
Greater New York City and what you see
here is the Brooklyn Historical Society
is founded by the elites of Brooklyn and
they're turning away from this
terrifying
to them polyglot present in che in favor
of a more culturally unified past where
English people arrived in the Americas
and they create the United States
contrast that with Cody's pageant where
you see all of these different peoples
of the world now sweeping West in a
grand pageant of frontier combat there's
lots of things we can say to criticize
this presentation of history among them
that white guys are always in control
right and non-english speaking people
are always subordinate and the Indians
are always at the bottom of the heap at
the end of the day we can say all of
that but at the same time it also
brought more people under its
mythological awnings it gave people
different people's a place in the larger
story of world history and it connected
them to American history how did Cody
come up with that well it's this search
for larger audiences to create bigger
and bigger a bigger and bigger take at
the box office you appeal to more and
more people he democratized his
entertainment at the same time American
historians including Frederick Jackson
Turner in Wisconsin are busy trying to
democratize American history by telling
stories of immigrants arriving in the
wilderness being won over and becoming
Americans by the process of as easy as
he put it winning that wilderness by the
1890s though the greatest appeal of the
show was less what went on in the arena
than in the show community itself which
figured most prominently in press
accounts at the moment when reformers
struggled to gain control of cities in
settlement houses and public health
campaigns Buffalo Bills frontier
simulacrum seemed to anticipate the
modern city at least as much as it
recalled the vanished frontier there
were six hundred and eighty people in
the Wild West Show that year journalists
called it the little tented City and the
show was in many respects a traveling
company town where it required which
required three trains to move the
animals the props the cast and a vast
support staff of wheelwrights butchers
cooks their show required twenty three
thousand yards of canvas and
20 miles of rope all of these statistics
were widely touted in the press at the
time and watching the crews unload cars
and unload and erect the equipment and
the tents was a popular diversion
voguing a factory production the mobile
kitchen was a favorite subject they had
five ovens a zinc lined refrigerator man
it was manned by three cooks and 38
waiters serving hundreds of gallons of
coffee 800 orders of pancakes and a
thousand steaks every day this is the
Wild West Show dining tent on the 4th of
July the camp's infrastructure
reinforced its vision of modernity
journalists hailed the Wild West camp
for having attributes that many people
desired for Brooklyn they said when you
get here you can't see it so much in
this picture which is black and white
and kind of grainy but these were the
tents for the soldiers and you see the
teepees over here and they've planted
trees and there were actually garden
plots of flowers planted around the
grounds so that one journalist said on
the large plot of wasteland there's been
laid out a beautiful summer Park with
trees shrubbery and beautiful Pat
beautiful paths the Wild West Show
symbolically settled the city's dark
edges the show also advertised workplace
temperance which kept the workers on
task vaccination campaigns which they
had among the cast to prevent outbreaks
of disease among the show community and
this really struck journalists because
when public health authorities had tried
to vaccinate people in Brooklyn
vaccinations were so unknown at the time
and people were so suspicious of them
that they locked their doors and poured
hot water out of their upper storey
roofs on to the public health staff
rather than take vaccinations and to
watch this polyglot cast of Indians and
cowboys and Mexican Vaqueros and Gauchos
arrived and just take vaccinations
seemed to betoken something really
forward-looking
Cody's little tempted cities suggested
modernity too in its technology the
telephone in Cody's tent and the
electricity that lit the arena and the
show grounds it was this in these early
years in the 1890s that the electric
trolley begins to run in Brooklyn
and the trolley when it starts is
actually quite dangerous dozens of
people are killed by the trolley because
you can't hear it coming the way you
could hear horses coming when they
pulled those old horse cars so seven
something like 17 people are killed in
one year on one Brooklyn trolley line in
1892 and 93 this is why Brooklyn Heights
become known as trolley Dodgers and why
Brooklyn's baseball team would become
the Brooklyn Dodgers the baseball team
to which that big public is going and
immigrants are flocking because they too
want to be American to visit the Wild
West Show was to become literate to
assume a ritual of Americanization and
this the modern electrical generators
were part of that the the Statue of
Liberty had been lit up in 1886 and Cody
lit up his show in 1894 and started
offering shows at night with these
electrical generators built by Thomas
Edison in time he got mobile generators
to go on the road with the show and they
toured in the cast parade through the
streets that's one of the generators in
the cast parade as sort of stars of the
show in their own right the
electrification of the show implied a
symbolic parallel between show and
nation each of which originated on the
frontier and advanced to modernity
hundreds of Engineers would tour the
show and actually write articles about
its electrical works the show was not
only a spectacle of the past but a
harbinger of the future a complete
reenactment of civilizations rise from
nature to technology the maturation of
her people from buffalo hunters to
electrical engineers for a managerial
class that was beset by strikes and work
stoppages and labor unrest Cody did
become a special kind of icon a natural
manager who could manage what looked
like a modern city and he came from
frontier origins as this modern city
seemed to the success of the whole thing
suggested that corporate bosses and the
managers who work for them and among
those managers were many children of
immigrants many american-born children
of immigrants are becoming managers on
shop floors and in officers at this time
it's sick Joe he suggested that to be a
manager was to have a space
place in American history as if managing
people was a frontier attribute like
hunting Buffalo in its glory days then
Buffalo Bill's Wild West stood as much
for America as for the region of the far
west but in a sense just at the moment
that the Wild West Show in the modern US
seemed to resonate most with one another
the United States changed in ways that
brought Cody's dream crashing down his
heavy investments in building the town
of Cody Wyoming and in mines in Arizona
and the competition of the movies soon
took a toll by 1908 he'd combined his
show with that of a competitor Pawnee
bill Lilly and by 1913 his show was on
the auction block in bankruptcy court he
ended his days as a town builder trying
to bring the best of civilization to
Wyoming he put it partly in an effort to
make that final chapter of civilizations
progress come true for him I think Cody
really did come to believe that the
story of progress could be his story and
that his life should end with him a
wealthy and revered town founder in the
end that story of progress failed him
personally but in its glory days the
Wild West Show was a kind of community
that offered not only a vision of
American history but hints of its bright
future from public health to Prohibition
electrification to professional social
management a great deal of the modern US
seemed to swirl out of this spectacle of
American history there was something
more than the past circular circulating
around the arena around the Indians that
Cossacks the cowboys and Mexicans
between the garden plots and the
electrical generating plants that lit
the grounds in the spaces between the
modern tent that was Cody's office with
its telephone and office furniture and
between the smoky Indian teepees
something else flitted about there in
sparkling and alluring fragments at the
corner of our vision the future
glimmered thanks
I'll take questions and and the spokes
from c-span are going to boom for
questions which as a term I love like
people will used to boomtowns in the old
days and swear to you that Carthage
Kansas who's gonna be the next capital
of this state all right we're gonna boom
four questions here so question over
here yes the Native Americans who
performed in the show did any extensive
number of them either relate their
experiences orally or in writing in a
way that they could be collected and did
you have access to those sources did any
extensive number of the American Indians
in the show relate their experiences
some did Nicholas Black Elk famously in
Black Elk speaks tells quite a story
about being in the Wild West Show also
Luther Standing Bear in his book my
people the Sioux talks about being in
the Wild West Show and both of them
speak very highly of the experience
there are other accounts that exist and
I interviewed a number of interviewed a
couple of people who are descendants of
Indian performers in the show and I
managed to get some family accounts
there there's also family accounts the
account of the dull knifes George Stone
life was in the show guide old life was
in the Wild West Show with Buffalo Bill
and you can can read about his
experiences in the dull knifes of Pine
Ridge by Joe star Rita
there isn't a vast archive of this
however and not not that many people in
the Wild West Show actually left written
accounts of it you really have to scrape
around to find letters and press
commentary other questions over here
from will over here I have to wait for
the microphone to get over to here so
I'm standing think about asking more
questions over here so we don't run this
our poor producers ragged back here with
the microphone
yes Duke yeah I'm wondering if there's
evidence that Turner that Frederick
Jackson Turner actually visited the Wild
West Show at the 1893 Chicago World's
Fair
I don't what he thought about it I never
saw that any evidence that suggested
I think Turner would was was really
nervous at the 1893 World's Fair because
he was presenting a paper at the
American Historical Association and I
know what that's like and and it was hot
I I really don't know if you know if he
visited the Wild West Show I think it
would have thought of it as kind of
frivolous and and not really what he
wanted to talk about that's my hunch
because Theodore Roosevelt felt a little
bit worried about his own relationship
to the Wild West Show for example but I
don't I don't have an answer to that
question he may have the evidence the
truth is out there as somebody said on
some great television production once
right another question over here be
brave be bold yeah there's a there's a
question no down here okay go ahead so
so with respect to all these different
groups that were in the show do you know
if there was also of these social
hierarchies within the show itself that
were the Indians treated equal or were
they also relegated to this lower social
ladder within the show itself Indians
generally the testimony you get is that
Indians found that it was the best place
to work that they experienced off the
reservation and that they got a lot of
deference a lot of difference was shown
to them in terms of things like the in
the dining tent in particular Luthor's
Standing Bear would talk about how Cody
wouldn't allow them to be given inferior
food even though once in a while a cook
would try that and that there were
rivalries between the contingents
between cowboys and Indians at times and
that kind of thing happened but in
general what you find is there is a kind
of rough I want to say a rough
collegiality almost that arises among
show performers so that when there are
brawls among with townspeople which
happens sometimes everybody joins in
together that's a circus tradition where
the whole cast would join in to fend off
the
the other thing you have to remember
about the Wild West Show which I didn't
go into here is that a lot of the
cowboys or actually Indians who dressed
up as Cowboys know Indians
well Indians were never played by
anybody but Indians right but Indians in
the show dressed up as Cowboys some of
them some of the Cowboys some of the
white Cowboys in the show we're married
to Lakota women and spoke Lakota so
there's a lot of family connections that
cut across the show as well and a lot of
a lot of Mexican Americans or possibly
Mexicans I can't tell from the documents
also we're Cowboys in the show and
there's a lot a lot of Spanish spoken
all the way around so that the hierarchy
thing seems to dissolve after a time
when you've been touring with people and
working with them I would say down here
Patti wet let's wait for the mic we'll
play some interlude music yes not
Richard White's
it's always fun to argue with Richard I
just wondered if you could sort of state
what Richard said about Buffalo Bill and
say if you ended up agreeing with with
that interpretation of right reconquest
and that kind of stuff so and then I'm
also wondering how you are gauging
Buffalo Bills fame and lasting memory
are people what's his name recognition
as you travel around are you finding
that he's really he's doing better than
then Hugh Grant I mean you know so just
to pick one where is he yeah where is it
yeah yeah it's really as everything is
with Buffalo Bill it's all really weird
your first question though about Richard
White's arguments about the Wild West
Show Richard argues that the Wild West
Show prevent presented an inverted
version of the conquest that is in real
life white America had essentially waged
an aggressive series of campaigns
against Indians and effectively stolen
Indian land and
country in the Wild West Show it's
always Indians who are invading white
people's home territory and the white
people have no choice but to respond
with equivalent force that's certainly
true
the Richards absolutely white about that
I write about the Richard is Richard
white sorry
and on book TV - I a Richards absolutely
right about that the the issue though is
that that interpretation was just it's
completely pervasive in the culture I
mean you you couldn't read about Indian
Wars without some journalists piping up
saying and these poor settlers who just
wanted to move to Oklahoma and claim
their little hundred and sixty acres of
land and there should be room enough for
everybody
ah these Indians that Justin but you
couldn't read the coverage without kind
of running across that story before the
Wild West Show I think even so yes it's
right but I don't think it it explains
the larger a lure of the stories telling
cuz the story is telling wouldn't have
been new then how's Buffalo Bill doing
in the popularity stakes and the
celebrity stakes everywhere I go there
are people who say Buffalo Bill is he
some kind of circus guy wasn't he a fake
or they kinda have a vague idea they
might have heard of him once and then
there are all these people who pipe up
with my great-grandfather saw him I used
to hear this story I heard this
especially in in Europe where Buffalo
Bills memory is revered I heard stories
from people I had a friend who said he
has his great-grandfather fought at the
Somme in World War one did loads of
things but the story he would always
tell you was about seeing Buffalo Bill's
Wild West in Leeds in 1904 I think it
was right and my neighbors I had two
elderly neighbors who are very active in
the pro gay marriage campaign very
active big civil rights and human rights
activists and ice met them I saw them
again at the at the block party we
recently had and I told them they said
what are you up to I so I've got a book
out what's it about old Buffalo Bill oh
he's my hero one of them announced yeah
and you get it for the most interesting
places I mean there are a lot of people
in Wyoming who think Buffalo Bill is
great
a local right but you you do find this
even in in California even among people
you'd think really weren't reading much
Western history or it had much exposure
to him so it's kind of still around as a
vague presence yes to add to what you're
just saying I was living in France for
the last five years and the French are
fascinated with him and and I'd always
heard Buffalo Bill but my first you know
to go out and read and figure this out
was because of the French you know the
French fascination with Buffalo Bill
that's in him coming to France with his
own trains yes and loading onto the
French rail system and traveling and
it's absolutely right they reenact the
Wild West Show at that's at Disneyland
Paris you got to go it's like the best
thing going it was great
I went to this thing and my kids I took
my kids along and and you know I felt
guilty because I was calling this
research right and was set in the Wild
West Show and is you know there were a
lot of things that weren't as realistic
as you'd like but the writing was
tremendous and the Indians were Canadian
and us Indians and I interviewed a way
interviewed one who was from The Crow
Reservation in Montana and I asked him
how was it working in the show he said
hey I get paid to be an Indian what can
I say
and he was really excited cuz he got
that night he said I get to play Sitting
Bull tonight I'm really you know that
kind of thing you know just this
constant back and forth and Indian
performers today of course many many
Indian performers tour in Europe right
we danced troops and so forth very
popular I can't tell you the number
times again lectures like this and
people will tell me
I met a troop of Blackfeet dancers in
Paris last year I just had that story
come back to me many times for example
yes I'm curious about Buffalo Bill
because I think he died broke yeah and
then he was resurrected and then now
he's buried in Colorado could you just
say a few words on how he how that came
about and why he was buried in Colorado
yeah he made terrible investments as you
know
I'm sympathetic it's he felt that he
should be able to invest in mining and
in town building and just about anything
and and it would be a successful forum
as show business and it just never was
his gold mines started turning out
tungsten instead of gold and it just
didn't pay off for him so he lost huge
amounts of money and he borrowed against
the Wild West Show to have it to fund
his other businesses so when he died he
had very little money his wife
Louisa she had money in and she was she
had several properties and so forth but
he died in Denver at his sister's house
and Henry Taman the publisher of The
Denver Post which had been written
absolutely scurrilous stories about
Buffalo Bill right they offered Taman
offered to pay for Cody's funeral if
he'd be buried at Lookout Mountain and
Louisa agreed to do this so they were so
worried that the karez identity of Cody
would steal his body because it was well
known it was in this will that he wanted
to be buried in the town of Cody they
were so worried about this then they
blasted a shaft in the side of the
mountain I don't know how deep it is you
can ask Steve riesen up there runs a
great museum it's just terrific and said
Colorado State Park and they put Cody's
body in it filled with concrete and they
bolted steel plate on top and at various
times during the 1920s they parked the
National Guard tank over the top of it
when there were rumors that the foreign
the the American Legion from Cody was
going to come down and make a midnight
raid and there's some people who say to
me oh no his body's not in there it's
gone and in that he takes place with all
those other great sort of enigmatic
planesman Crazy Horse right and of
course not to mention enigmatic
celebrities like Elvis right where is he
I think he's buried on the mountain and
that's more or less the story of how it
got there I think we're out of time
any book side and I know people do want
cook sign which we said they want five